In the section on error handling,
we used the @objc attribute to expose an
enum of type ErrorType to Objective-C.
When I place that modifier in
front of this particular enum,
the compiler doesn't like it very much.
Okay, let's see what
the compiler has to say here.
@objc enum raw type 'String'
is not an integer type.
So I'm reminded to change
this to an integer.
And of course I have to change
the values to integers, too, and
the error goes away.
And now I'm able to access these
error codes from the parts of my
project that are written in Objective-C.
These compiler errors
can be really helpful
because they flag code that would
otherwise be silently ignored.
For example, let's say we're
back in our house class and
we've added a Swift struct
to represent a hot tub.
If I mark this HotTub struct with
an @objc attribute, I see an error.
@objc can't be applied
to this declaration.
And of course I'm reminded that
Objective-C can't consume structs.
So I edit my HotTub to be a class.
I make sure it inherits from NSObject.
I edit these functions a little bit.
And now when I add the @objc attribute,
I don't see that error any more.
I can see that there's no problem.
Although, now that HotTub
inherits from NSObject,
I actually don't need
the @objc attribute any more.